free Palestine the violence in the
Middle East brought out protesters with
a message to dignitaries attending the
hallifax International Security Forum
this weekend we're losing people we're
losing children and that's not okay
anywhere there's nothing Jewish about
violence so I'm here to call for a
ceasefire earlier inside a former prime
minister of Israel said the state cannot
stop until Hamas is defeated if Israel
government cannot survive cannot live up
to its very basic commitment to its
citizens uh if Hamas can control or come
back as a military power as Russia
continues its attack on Ukraine and
tensions in Asia persist there is
evidence people around the world are
fearful amidst it all a new poll
conducted on behalf of the Halifax
International Security Forum has found
that across 30 countries the majority of
people last Feel the world has become
more Danger dangerous over the past year
in fact the ipsus poll found 84% feel
that way 70% said they expect a global
conflict similar to the world wars in
the next 25 years and 69% worry about
the potential of Chinese Le conflict in
Asia similar to Russia's attack on
Ukraine those figures slightly down from
last year although the poll was taken
before the Hamas attack on Israel the
public understands that it's a it's a
pretty messy dangerous place out there
and that we've gone through particularly
through the course of the pandemic a lot
of disruption disruption leads to other
disruption it should be a reason for all
of us to be engaged for this American
law and policy Professor the feeling of
insecurity should be met with action to
defend democracy both outside and within
home borders if we can't make sure that
we live in functioning democracies we're
not going to be of much use to anybody
else for many dealing with this time of
unrest has meant protests like this
Heidi Peta Global News Halifax